well it's quite shocking really and
annoying because whenever i park my car
in a no parking spot you can bet a
street warden is just around the corner
to give me a ticket but when the mafia
is trying to get its dirty money cleaned
there's not enough staff around to check
it
well let's get someone in to shed some
light on this issue christian hamburg
he's the managing director of
transparency international germany and
he's an expert on the difficult subject
of money laundering it's very good to
have you here and it is a difficult
subject because for once
somehow it doesn't seem to be quite
clear why money laundering is actually
such a big problem who just get hurt by
it
money laundering is the necessary
necessary
necessary instrument
by which a criminals or kleptocrats or
dictators can bring the money that they
have acquired illegally into the legal
system and without money laundering they
would sit on their money but not being
able to spend it therefore if we want to
suspend these activities we also have to
fight money laundering okay so it's a
really serious criminal offence and the
oecd is also
putting it in context with a terrorism
financing so it's certainly nothing to
just shrug your shoulders about uh but
at the same time it seems to be quite
surprising that germany turns out to be
so attractive uh for money laundering
how come how did this happen
i think there are two reasons one reason
is that germany is considered a safe
haven a safe country if you have money
here you feel you will still have it in
20 years and i think the second reason
is that
the regulations in germany fighting
money laundering are not as strictly
enforced as in other comparable
countries and i think that's something
that we really have to look at and where
politicians have to act but why is that
i mean i just mentioned the example of
the uh parking space that you
immediately get a ticket so with these
small offenses the authorities are there
immediately why not with something as
big as money laundering
i think one problem is that for the
non-financial sectors and that's for
example jewelry or car dealers
and the local authorities that also look
after your parking ticket they are
responsible for
checking on anti-money laundering
efforts but for the financial sector
they we have a central unit and it makes
a lot of sense in something as complex
as fighting money laundering to have a
central authority and that not to have
hundreds and hundreds of people locally
trying
to deal with this matter and what are
the chances that we will see such a
central authority coming to be in
i think there have been debates in the
past and i would also assume that the
international pressure on germany to
change
this
these standards is high so we we would
hope for change also in other areas
for example we need a beneficial
ownership register in germany so you can
see who's really behind the company
these are other measurements we do have
something like a trade register and bank
accounts you also need a name for that
we have a trade register but we don't
know who the real beneficial owner is
behind the company very often and it's
now many countries pushing for such a
register where germany is still very
skeptical and is kind of
not in line with what is planned at the
european level in brussels and i think
it's important that we really know who's
behind a company and that we can see
that in a register okay well maybe the
oecd pressure will change something
about that christian homework thank you
very much for joining us